wir sprechen über den
gesundheitsminister und ordentlich
verwirrung um die korona regeln wieder
einmal muss man leider sagen hier sehen
sie die seite 2 heute von bild die
verwirrungen auch vom
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach geht
sie diesmal aus ja wer genau weiß ich
jetzt noch mal impfen lassen oder vor
allen dingen auch ja gut auf womit nun
mit welchem impfstoff auch das nicht
klar und soll man sich künftig wirklich
alle drei monate impfen lassen kann doch
gar nicht sein am abend hat der minister
versucht wenigstens ein bisschen
klarheit in die auch selbst gestiftete
verwirrung oder umgekehrt her indem er
sich vom krankenbett aus zu wort
gemeldet hat
der gesundheitsminister krank immer noch
corona geschwächt und doch gibt er
interviews mir geht es wieder besser
obwohl ich sagen muss also dass ich war
die symptome
regieren vom krankenbett die eigene
politik erklären das muss lauterbach
denn er hat neue corona verwirrung
gestiftet mit der 3 monats im frieden
nur wer frisch geimpft ist darf noch
ohne maske oder ohne tests in
restaurants oder kinos gehen soll man
sich jetzt etwa alle drei monate impfen
lassen also ich glaube es wird im moment
wollte die verwirrung stiften wollen zum
beispiel ich habe nie gesagt dass alle
jüngeren leute sich jetzt impfen lassen
sondern das ist einfach falsch das wird
immer wieder unterstellt das ist aber
nicht richtig das habe ich nie gesagt
und so ist es auch doch das hat
lauterbach eben doch gesagt beim spiegel
am 14 juli ich selbst würde es wie folgt
macht also wenn jemand den sommer
genießen und will kein risiko gehen
beispielsweise zu erkranken vielleicht
auch länger zu erkranken oder anlagen
sowie zu erkranken dann würde ich in
absprache natürlich mit dem hausarzt
würde ich auch jüngeren die impfung
empfehlen die stiko empfiehlt ja jetzt
nur sagen beim allgemeinen aber die
umwelt schaden ist ja immer eine
entscheidung zwischen hausarzt und dem
betroffenen also was geht denn nun
nein ich habe nicht gesagt für alle die
vierten punkt nur darauf hingewiesen
dass wir auch eine botschaft für die
unter 60-jährigen oder die unter
70-jährigen benötigt man zum beispiel
soll eine solche impfung dann
stattfinden in absprache mit dem arzt
oder also wovon hängt das ab zum
beispiel jemand der ganz besonders viele
kontakte hat die man zum beispiel der
krank ist und somit viele risiken und
noch eine frage herr lauterbach wie soll
man künftig erkennen im restaurant wer
frisch geimpft ist kriegt er einen
stempel
geplant ist dass auf der krone war nicht
einfach das zertifikat zu lange wie die
drei monate noch nicht um es in eine
andere farbe hat somit also dass noten
normale eben zertifikat lhasa blau
erscheint wurde dann sicher weise in
grün erscheinen so dass beim reingehen
jeder sofort sieht das ist ein frisches
kapital
[Musik]